la question se pose également une
demande en termes différents mais pour
montréal vous savez que michel labrecque
a été nommé le grand patron l'aerio la
régie des installations olympiques cela
wagon soir bonfoh réseau et c'est encore
d'actualité parce que quand on se
promène un peu autour du stade on voit
ce béton qui fissure et à plusieurs
endroits qui a vieilli malades aux
endroits de ce débat du toit mais
allons-y globalement d'abord est-ce que
aussi qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
collectivement avec ce qu'il reste des
neiges
collectivement c'est à dire moi je vais
le décomposer parce que si vous preniez
le vélodrome de montréal n'a été
convertis en bio dont ça si vous
regardez au pourtour il ya des jeunes
dynamiques avec espace vie avec le
jardin botanique le parc maisonneuve
insectarium tout ça mais on a vu arriver
le planétarium qui était donnée
terrienne d'arc était dans l'ouest donc
qui a à l'heure actuelle une coagulation
de choses
le football est plus dense and ear ans
d'intervalle mawson le soccer est
pendante stadiers dans le stade saputo
keita côté pédagogique la tour est un
attrait touristique constant un bon an
mal an l'esplanade dont vous parlez
depuis deux ans elle était animée mon
prédécesseur avait mis un programme de
relance les piscines sont utilisés sont
en rénovation
le stade accueille parfois du sport -
d'expulsion parce que la période de
pointe des expositions c'est l'hiver
l'automne mais avec les déchirures du
toit plat le devoir de précaution qu'on
a on n'est pas là donc là mais ce que je
voulais je vais enrober ce port enrobé
mais répond sobrement
vous savez ces 40 ans d'histoire mais
c'est un équipement qu'on va mesurer sur
100 ans
quand je vois sotchi une station
balnéaire je ne vois pas comment ils
vont réussir à opérer ce au plus que les
événements qui s'en viennent en ligne à
cinq prochaines années mais disons qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de leçons alors faire
pour du stade génie en terme de
gouvernance et là ça fait un an jean
françois lisée nous disait qu l'an
dernier la lave ambitions sur le toit
article finalement l'autre ministre bis
rue pascal bérubé a dit non non non jean
françois lisée trop énervé pas tout de
suite
et là ça s'est passé un peu perdu par le
débat qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le toit
du stade selon vous quelle est
présentement le toit que nous avons est
en fin de vie utile
il ya des déchirures con
documente chacun il est ausculté tous
les jours il est accusé d' affront deux
fois par année et il ya un audit de
génie aux cinq ans donc il est très
sérieusement suivie
là il ya un dossier d'affaires initial
en jargon que les téléspectateurs c'est
que pour éviter les erreurs du passé je
peux vous dire que le toutes les pierres
sont retournées et c'est pour ça que
peut-être que l'empressement qu'on
voudrait la moins en arrivant là je suis
plutôt je passe sur les freins mais je
veux m'assurer que la prochaine décision
que le gouvernement va prendre
il est toute l'information pour la
prendre de façon éclairée
madame marois nous disait dans une
entrevue à quelques mois je vais poser
la question directement ce que c'est
entre guillemets vendable à tous les
québécois de m 250 300 millions pour un
nouveau toit pour le seul père m'avait
dit pas vraiment et on sent texte est
très loin dans ses priorités
et depuis ce temps là hasard on ne peut
plus entendu parler ainsi la est-ce que
vous quand vous engagez vous avez dû
poser la question aurais-je du budget ce
qu'on veut en voir non jamais pour moi
le toit était pas j'ai pas accepter
parce que c'était pas il ya un toit
givet y'a pas toi jouait pour pas du
tout moi je veux que le stade olympique
on est une très bonne appréciation de
son déficit d'entretien
il faut qu'on le maintienne en bon état
puis pour la toi je veux que nous soyons
intellectuellement bardet pour que le
gouvernement prenne une décision si on
fait un toit qui goûte un compte commun
d'activités supplémentaires on va
pouvoir amener combien de revenus
supplémentaires on va pouvoir amener ces
travaux là n'ont pas été faits déjà on a
fait une présentation à québec les gens
qui vous ont précédé leur herriot on n'a
pas déjà oui oui mais oui mais c'est un
processus ou infrastructure québec vous
vous souvenez peut-être le gouvernement
suite à des dérapages dans les projets
en termes d'envergure de budget délai a
décidé d'imposer encore un chemin très
très ponctué doigt dans le meilleur
scénario possible ses 40 ans
1017 on va fêter le 375e de montréal
dans le meilleur scénario à ce qu'on
aura un nouveau toit un nouveau stade
revampé pour 2017 ou c'est illusoire
difficile difficile au moment où je vous
parle j'ai une journée dans le cadre le
sais mais je pourrais vous dire ça mais
pour l'instant ce que j'en vois là les
étapes suivantes difficile mais possible
si le dossier tient vraiment la route
mois pour moi pas question que nous
refusions une erreur dans la décision
économique d'aller de l'avant parce que
la question qui est montréalais supposer
que les québécois un se pose c'est ce
qu' un avenir vraiment pour ce stade là
et si on répond oui ça prend un toit
rapidement qui est fonctionnel pour
qu'il ya des événements pendant l'hiver
ne promet pas le cas des cas de la même
un peu plus clair dès le stade on
démolit repos entre pauvres peuvent pas
sous mon môme et 5 1 puis pas de votre
vivant et pas question qu'on fasse on
n'a pas su et sang et eau là pour payer
cela il est magnifique le stand pour un
stade américains qui ont démoli pour
construire un homme là qu'on voit le
garder on voit l'entretenir
on voit le protéger et on va s'assurer
que si on maintient on prend la décision
en termes d'envergure de budgets et
délais pour que le gouvernement prenne
une décision que tous les québécois mon
bon monsieur labrecque tu finis mes
excuses at il dit
si on met un toit commun quel autre
scénario peut exister recherce antoine
jachère c'est à dire qu'on démonte le
toit quand tu voyais complètement finie
on entrepose on hivernent comprend ainsi
que d'un certain nombre d'années pour
soi poser la question comme il a été
pendant dix ans le stade de paul toit
pendant dix ans 1,65 m
au printemps il ya de la neige encore m
il ya des matches qui s'en viennent mais
les matches après du du football
pourrait se tenir là donc la période
avril leur top est encore opérationnel
mais disons que le meilleur potentiel
pour aller chercher des grandes
expositions des grands salons
tout ça c'est bien évidemment avec un
toit je m'attendais ce que vous me
rendiez ça plus vite on doit avoir un
toit puis je vais là québec
je vais l'automne pas aujourd'hui le
prude un pee wee parce que si vous
entendu vos jambes on ne fera pas de toi
devant baisse
garder ma leurs données les données pour
qu'il prenne une décision
c'est beaucoup d'argent on veut mais en
même temps si on va chercher des revenus
supplémentaires ça peut se justifier
chez labrecque on va en reparler merci
de nous voir dont vous venez d'arriver
oui voilà j'ai 12 heures dans le cas
c'est le courage et merci